greets everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my youtube channel where we just hit a
hundred thousand subscribers hopefully
[ __ ] thank you guys so much I have a
whole bunch of content planned including
doing this QA live but I'm actually in
Texas until you use and I didn't expect
to hit 100,000 subscribers until early
next year so I'm not prepared for this
at all so that's a book a blessing and a
curse and then I hit 100,000 way before
I expect it to but also I can't do the
stuff that I wanted for you guys so I
will make up for that in January in a
little of all that I'm just going to
make this Q&A a little bit longer than
normal and as per usual I'm not
answering questions that I have answered
before not gonna answer my game of year
because I'm gonna have a separate video
about that and I also tend to not answer
stop that I don't have an interesting
answer to so let's get started milk on
the school stage on Instagram asked cup
size when you're ordering from the
don'ts of course no I can't like to go
on medium because I feel like a lodge at
McDonald's by the time you get to the
bottom of the soda all the ice is melted
so it's really watery but on the other
hand small is so small but it's almost
entirely ice and not enough soda whereas
mediums like right in the middle miss so
cup size medium Yusuf Khan on Instagram
oz do you have any regrets I don't have
a whole lot of regrets um the only ones
that I do have are related to
relationships I definitely stayed in
some relationships far too long a ton of
people ask this question including came
avala on Instagram I'm dying to know
what you think of awaken my love which
is Childish Gambino's new album for
those who don't already know chops can
be now is the number one music artist
that I listen to awaken my love is not
what I want from Dan bina but I still
think as a piece of music it is very
good I'm also just [ __ ] constantly
impressed by that man's talent is that
literally anything he can't do Gina
Anglo Lisa Rodriguez on Facebook asked
can you even know like seriously oh my
god I can't even stop you're killing me
Sofia Maria Paula Tina on instagram
asked you excited about the Last of Us -
and what new games are you looking
forward to the most
yes I'm excited about the loss of us -
of course I didn't want that game to be
from Joel and Ellie's perspective
actually I was kind of hoping it would
be a game in the same
but not with the two of them because the
last of us one has one of the best
endings in any video game or any media
ever to kind of cheapen that ending by
ultimately turning something into a
franchise really sucks but then I saw
some of the panels that the node Edo
team did at PSX and it seems like this
isn't a decision that they made lightly
they did put a lot of thought into it
and games I'm looking forward to next
Geo
I'm totally gonna forget something but
Red Dead obviously ukelele horizon zero
dawn Zelda Oh what else is coming out
next year isn't the ball to come to mind
totally gonna be things that I've
forgotten about that crown resident on
Instagram - what's your favorite brand
of clothing the only like brand that I
am actually a loyal to is supers shoes
surprise anyone from super happens to
want to sponsor me get in touch because
I'll be all about that magnitude 1 1 7
is there a game series you would like to
ever appear in mocap or voice I think if
I were to be in a video game I would
want it to be Gears of War totally
unrelated to the fact that I recently
did to Kate Diaz cosplay I just feel
like ye as for me is a franchise that I
got really really involved in really
quickly thanks to the community by were
to give back to anyone I think that that
would be the community that I would want
to do it for rice to comment on you to
ask how do you feel about the idea of
safe spaces I feel the same way that I
feel about most other things if that's
the thing that you think that you need
go for it Nick sub on Instagram also I
know you like under oath you listen to
any other aggressive bands I kind of
stopped listening to hog or
post-hardcore but I still have a lot of
old songs that I go back to I listen to
Parkway Drive Alexisonfire asking
alexandria a day to remember Chiodos
they're kind of different but I love
System of a Down so much also Taking
Back Sunday which is kind of more pop
punk right now I tend them mostly listen
to soundtracks or scores I absolutely
love just the kid Cody Dudley on
Facebook asks do you hang your toilet
paper over or under you know I don't
care about this as much as other people
do but I'm personally an over person oh
that's so excellent on Instagram asked
what are you looking forward to in the
new year I am
- ah TX Australia in Sydney the first
weekend in February and I cannot [ __ ]
wait I'm going because I've been seeing
my boyfriend for about yeah he lives
here in Texas he's gonna claim Australia
so that means he can meet my family and
that's the best I'm just so excited to
have like my family and my dog and my
boyfriend all in the same room for the
first time since I met him so that's
going to be amazing also planning to do
an overwatch cosplay it's not true sir
so that'll be at r-tx in Sydney if you
are coming to that that's roosterteeth
Expo for those who don't know come say
hi really really excited to be there
also Kojima is going to be there so
that's the [ __ ] best I love that man
so much Michael thought home written
isome huh Dan means that a name on
Facebook August who is your favorite
author I hadn't thought about this in
depth but it's probably Brandon
Sanderson
Gabrielle Mel gasa on Facebook asked
maybe not Q&A material but is your
tendinitis getting any better I'm
answering this question because a lot of
people actually have been asking me this
lately but I first had tendinitis in
this hand and then I had it in a brace
for about six months and I ended up
compensating and getting it in this hand
so this has been fine for a year this
hand has been fine for about three weeks
it's still not perfect
I went rock climbing the other day and
lifting myself up at one point really
hug but it is the best that has been in
a year I got 10 an item playing too much
video games turns out it happens to a
lot of people who work in games media
it's totally not uncommon and when I
went to Australia at the start of
November I really just made an effort to
take a break and that helped so much
Justin Bolden also asked if you don't
eat cereal what the [ __ ] does breakfast
look like in the Alana PS household this
is a thing I've spoken about on podcast
IGN I hate cereal I really don't like
cereal breakfast for me is pretty much
always a protein shake and oatmeal
oatmeal does not count as a cereal
cereal is sugary and [ __ ] Erin Alex
are araújo on Facebook oz if you had 1
million subscribers would you leave IGN
know my YouTube channel has never been a
Korea possibly Zack Griffin asks what
makes you interested in DJ I don't think
DJing is that different from
games honestly I think a lot of DJ's
agamas and it's just like moving the
dials at the exact right time and I
think probably the best thing about
DJing is that when you are doing the
thing correctly you see the reward in if
the crowd starts dancing but on a side
note here's a theory that I've heard
that I think totally applies to me DJ's
are the people who feel too awkward
dancing in a crowd so they have to DJ
instead what a set of thinking that I
feel I cannot dance unless I am like not
going to remember the night levels of
drunk Pedro Jaime Sierra on Facebook
asks how awesome is it that you no
longer have to worry about fighting
kangaroos mate
it's [ __ ] tops I don't want to
[ __ ] fight another kangaroo meal life
so stoked that I even have to touch them
anymore I don't even have to see them
down at the local park that's how people
think astray Liam sound that's not how
we sound only 1mdb on instagram asks how
does it feel having a dream job and
getting to travel all the amazing places
in the world
I am tired constantly I'm stressed
constantly I am sick constantly and that
is mostly because at the start of year I
was sick and then lights got cancelled
we had to go to Vegas and so we had to
road trip which meant that I got
pneumonia I had to take two weeks off I
was on coding the entire time and now
whenever anyone gets a cough I'm really
susceptible to getting it as well
because my lungs is God I'm very poor I
don't earn enough money to live in the
city that I walk in the trouble isn't
very glamorous because you fly somewhere
you're really tired because you have to
leave really early in the morning you go
straight to work and then have to go to
the hotel room and write about whatever
you saw and then go to sleep and repeat
the same thing the next day the
positives on the other hand oh why I'm
still here I am challenged every single
day I work with people who offer
insights and perspectives that I never
would have considered on things that I
love and then I get to work in an office
full of people who love the same games
and movies as I do and I think when you
work at a place like IGN for yeah it's
easy to forget that how lucky I am to
have everything in common with everyone
else in the room I love every single
thing that I get to work on and I feel
like in doing that I won some
new every single day I am absolutely
never bored I never hate what I'm doing
I'm always inspired both by the work
that I get to do and the people that I
get to do it with it's also the people
at conventions who come up to me
expecting absolutely nothing and say
something incredibly nice to me just to
be nice to conventions that I've been to
in Europe Paris games week in games Kong
and I had people come up to me in these
really thick accents didn't speak
English as a first language tell me that
they loved my content I was just about
to tell you guys that that makes me tear
up but I'm already doing it of course I
love my English speakers as well but the
fact that someone who doesn't speak
English as a first language washes the
stuff that I do or Rhys the stuff that I
write and made the effort to come up to
me in person and just share their
support with me
expecting absolutely nothing in return
except that I keep doing what I love
doing is amazing in synopsis I am
exhausting and I'm pretty sure that my
chosen career path is going to make me
die several years oh I love sickness and
stress but if I'm trading that off for
getting to constantly be challenged and
intellectually stimulated no question
I'm gonna keep doing it shifty under
school two one three on Twitter us
trailer is one of the few countries in
the world that enforces compulsory
voting biggest virtue biggest flaw in
your opinion biggest virtue is that the
parties don't have to spend a ton of
money on making people vote they don't
have to campaign in that same way
because everyone has to vote and people
just tend to vote for which one they
like kind of like more and don't as
often she says uncomfortably lie about
[ __ ] because again they don't have to do
that to make people vote because people
have to vote anyway the biggest flaw is
of course people wasting their boards
awarding the should they don't care
about but there are a lot of uneducated
voters and that does hurt the system dd
underscore T why on Twitter AHS to
journalism degree benefit you for your
work no [ __ ] waste of time the
revenant on Twitter ah since coming to
America what was the dumbest thing you
have ever witnessed one thing that I
find very very dumb and I only bring it
out because it has happened multiple
times is people not believing that it's
in Australia it's a very big country and
a ton of people also us if I have advice
for how to get into the job that I have
I would suggest that you watch the video
on my channel that I think is how I got
a full-time job at IGN is the title
every single component of how I got here
hopefully is broken down so go watch
that video thank you guys so so much for
asking questions and thank you the most
for a hundred thousand subscribers that
is crazy [ __ ] and I have to thank the
people who donated to my channel off to
the last video which is Michael crosa
again thank you so much Michael
and Osiris Leora I can't tell you guys
how much I appreciate that it really
does make a difference
several so many [ __ ] thank-yous you
guys okay I love you will someone just
have an amazing Christmas I will have a
new DJ mix up next week it's inspired by
a hotline man meaning stranger things
kind of retro music I'm very excited for
you guys to que that and then come next
year I'll do my top games of 2016 list
alrighty I will see you guys next time